I think drones are here to stay we're
going to use them we need to use them
and they're important part of what we do
and we actually going to use them even
more so I think that's important but
they are different they're different
because they are perceived differently
now if you think about it there are
several factors is the first is go back
to 1988 anybody remember what happened
in
1988 how many of you weren't born in
1988 that's very sad
uh president uh Clinton ordered Tomahawk
missile strikes into Afghanistan and to
the sedan in response to pretty clear
activities on the part of Usama Bin
Laden now if those tomk missiles didn't
kill ubl but they killed various people
created damage if you'd ask the average
American the next morning if we were at
War what would we have
said no we're not at War we fired some
tomw missiles if you were near the
impact point of a Tom missile and you
asked the next morning if they were at
war with America what do you think
they'd
say the answer is probably different so
if it lowers the threshold on the use of
military force it's dangerous and what I
mean if it it can be too casual it could
can seem too easy too too inexpensive
too risk-free and it increases your
likelihood of doing it then I would say
everyone who orders one ought to go
stand next to where one has gone off and
where you see body parts and and things
like that it's very different so I'm not
saying we don't use them I'm saying you
got to make sure you understand what
you're doing the other part of it is
perceptions we've got problems with some
Mexican drug lords in the US and whatnot
and the Mexicans are after them but what
if Mexico flew across the the border
with drones and did a missile strike in
Texas how would we
respond probably not well and it's the
perception
of we can step back and hurl
Thunderbolts like Thor without any risk
to ourselves that's viewed as arrogance
now whether that's right or wrong
perceptions matter in the world that's
why people go to war because they
perceive something so I think we've got
to be very very thoughtful
about how everything we do is actually
perceived by others again not throw out
the capacity entirely but be really
thoughtful about
it